Once you hit 50
it's likely that your circumstances may change significantly
over the next few years.
Perhaps you want to continue working until you reach state pension age
but cannot afford mortgage payments
by taking a mortgage term over a relatively short period.
Or you may currently have an interest only mortgage
coming towards the end of its term
but do not have the means to repay it.
But there is a misconception that if you're 50 or over
you're unable to obtain a mortgage
as it needs to be repaid by the time you retire.
This is not necessarily the case.
I specialise in arranging mortgages for clients who are either retired
or nearing retirement age
and would welcome any inquiries.
It is certainly not a case of one size fits all
and I'm I am able to look at your long term situation
and tailor the mortgage products to your specific circumstances,
taking into account any future pension income.
At Brunel, I have access to lenders that offer specific products
for clients over 50
that's not available through the usual high street banks.
If you are in a situation where you think I may be up to help,
please pick up the phone and give me a call.
There is no charge for advice
and I'm happy to look at your options for you.